welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is Eric Trexler I am the
special temporary primary host of this
podcast but today I am joined by Greg
Knuckles he's been on the show before
and he is currently the permanent guest
co-host for the time being Greg thank
you for joining me thanks for having me
back
um before we get into the content a few
reminders here if you like the show be
sure to like rate or subscribe wherever
you happen to get it if you want to
leave a positive review somewhere that
would also be nice if you want to stay
in touch with the stronger by science
universe and get periodic research
updates delivered right to your email go
ahead and join our newsletter you can do
that by going to strongerbyscience.com
newsletter it is linked in the show
notes today
if you are looking for a one-on-one
virtual coach we offer that as well you
can learn learn more by going to
strongerbyscience.com coaching if you
want to get a discount on very
reasonably priced supplements you can go
to bulksupplements.com use our code SBS
pod for a five percent discount and if
you'd like to support the show you could
subscribe to the mass research review
which comes out the first of the month
every single month or you can check out
the macro Factor Diet app which does
have a free trial so you can check it
out before you make any kind of
financial commitment sound good sounds
good to me all right so uh if you're
listening to this you're probably still
getting adjusted to the new uh schedule
for the podcast so just a reminder we
release a segment on our YouTube channel
uh on Wednesday then we release another
segment on Friday and then the following
Monday that's where the whole episode
comes out uh and that comes to YouTube
it also goes to all of our plot podcast
platforms
and the full episode contains both of
those segments plus a little bit of
extra chatter so if you wait and listen
to the whole episode you're not missing
anything at all and you actually have a
little bit of additional chatter in
there as well so you can consume this
content in whatever way you prefer in
whatever way you see fit
uh speaking of which uh we had some
intro chatter last episode and I have to
eat some Crow here uh this was a really
eye-opening experience for me so in the
last episode I think it was the most
recent one I speculated that only about
15 of men knew the difference between
shampoo and conditioner uh Greg I think
you pushed back a little bit about that
number and you actually did know the
difference well yeah in my kind of
cultural or my touch point there is I
do less personal grooming than I think
95 of people and therefore I think I
know less about personal grooming than
95 of people so my thinking was if I
know what conditioner is I assume most
people do yeah so there's two problems
with the 15 number that I put forward
first of all it's pretty narrow-minded
uh so I grew up in a culture and a time
period in which relatively few men ever
tried to maintain longer hairstyles uh
growing up in Ohio in the 90s long locks
were not really a thing that a lot of
gentlemen did but that cultural norm is
becoming pretty outdated pretty quickly
spiritually you grew up in the 50s uh
correct yeah when soon thereafter The
Beatles were scandalous exactly yeah so
so that cultural norm even where I where
I grew up is is already pretty outdated
and wasn't true 30 years prior so I
don't know why I just assumed like
that's just how the entire world works
and along those lines long hair among
men is very common in a large number of
cultures so uh very narrow-minded I
don't know why I just took my experience
and extrapolated it to the entirety of
humanity but I did uh so another issue
with that 15 number is that it's just
entirely wrong so since that day when we
recorded I genuinely took an interest in
this and I've been asking everyone
around me
regardless of of sex or gender do you
know the difference between shampoo and
conditioner every single person has
known it with an extreme amount of
detail and so I'm left to conclude that
apparently I'm just a complete dumbass
it's it's like one of those uh like late
night TV man on the street segments
where you're where you're trying to like
gotcha someone like yeah here's here's
the this thing that people seem to know
but like do you actually know what this
is but it's just you go to everyone on
the street and they're like of course I
know what that is yeah I I really
thought I was like oh this is a lot of
people are going to really really be
stumped by this every single person just
answers it correctly in extreme detail
and looks at me like why would you ask
that question so I thought it was about
15 uh like I said that was based on a
very narrow-minded perspective and just
being completely out of touch with the
entire world so uh I do want to note
since I mentioned my my
narrow-mindedness I'm sure some people
are going to think that I got a bunch of
negative feedback and I'm succumbing to
cancel culture and acknowledging my
narrow Viewpoint uh we are recording
this before that episode actually has
been published yeah so no one has
corrected me on that but I felt so
stupid about how wrong I was that I
literally sat down and reflected on it
and I said
how how have I been so wrong in this
particular instance so I really dug into
it and said on how many different uh
levels could I have misinterpreted uh
this particular thing so
I'm just very stupid and I'm sorry for
being stupid it's all good and you know
it takes a big person to to be able to
take the L like this right on the chin
and keep moving forward so I appreciate
you for that yeah so so what do you got
here yeah so uh I've got two two fun
research related tools that might be
worth checking out for people who uh
want to keep up to date with the
research but also who maybe have
research related questions and don't
necessarily want to do like a systematic
literature search to try to get answers
to those questions so within the last
two or three months I have become aware
of two tools called consensus and elicit
in both of these tools like their their
websites you can just go to and they use
machine learning to extract answers to
questions from the scientific literature
so you know if like you could go to one
of them and say like uh like does
creatine or how much hypertrophy does
creatine cause or something like that
um and you know it'll it'll do its thing
and try to find an answer to that
question for you from the literature uh
complete with citations and you know
papers that you could read related to
the question you're asking to try to get
more clarity on the subject
um and I I've played around with both of
these tools
and I think that they're
I would I would say that they're
probably like 70 80 percent of the way
there so if you're like an academic or
if you're just trying to go really deep
on a particular topic make sure you get
all of the supporting literature for a
particular subject
um these aren't going to do the job for
you but if you're you know just trying
to get your feet wet in a particular
area of the literature or if there's
just a question you have where you don't
necessarily care about knowing all of
the background information like all of
the context all of the nuance and
getting really really deep into it and
and just trying to get a rough idea
about what the literature says about a
particular topic I I think these are are
definitely two very useful tools for
that
um so yeah just uh just be aware of both
of them we'll put them in the show notes
and uh yeah they're they're cool and fun
to play around with yeah that that's
more useful than my opening segment but
uh no that that's interesting I'm
curious to see how quickly some of these
machine learning online tools are going
to develop because I think I heard of
something else that it's like you type
in a prompt and it does like a digital
rendering like a drawing yeah like what
you typed in
um and yeah so it's interesting to see
machine learning starting to I think
that's based on machine learning that
other one right I assume but but yeah
some of these like kind of they're
they're marketed as like AI type
applications and websites I'm curious to
see if uh if they really start to fill
in and progress over the next like five
or ten years but but ultimately I
absolutely have no idea so we'll see
yeah you know with the
um
with like the the AI prompt thing where
you can just type something and it'll
make a painting from it uh there was
someone who like I don't remember all of
the details but uh someone won like an
art contest somewhere with a painting
that was made from one of those prompts
um or not a painting but like a digital
art contest and uh
like just following the discourse of
that on Twitter people were very upset
about it but I I thought it was kind of
ironic because like
I'll fully admit I don't
I don't get Modern Art I don't think uh
and I'm sure that sounds uncultured to
say
um you know and and I certainly don't
begrudge people who who do get it like I
don't think they're full of [ __ ] I don't
begrudge people who like it I just I
just think I'm not cultured enough to
understand it but like a big part of
kind of the early parts of that movement
was kind of like deconstructing what art
is in the first place
um
and for kind of like traditionalists
that made them very upset but now like
using AI to make things that are
visually appealing that people recognize
as art that can maybe win an art contest
that seems to be like deconstructing the
concept of like what an artist is yeah
um and so it's it's kind of like the
artists are getting a taste of their own
medicine like deconstruct this
[ __ ] uh yeah anyway
I I just think it's cool yeah I was
talking to a school teacher the other
day and apparently the the big thing
they're worried about now is
um
basically AI tools where you put in a a
work that has been written and instead
of plagiarizing it word for word that
you tell the AI like hey can you like
rephrase this a little bit yeah it does
it and apparently uh kids in schools
these days are starting to use that to
turn in uh essays that they had like
literally nothing to do with so yeah
it's interesting times ahead
um yeah I don't know you know I I think
I think it'll be interesting to see how
how like education adjusts to things
like that because like I remember when
we were going through school uh in math
class teachers would be like you got to
learn how to do this stuff it's not like
you're you're gonna go around through
life with a calculator in your pocket
but like psych we are like we all have
calculators in our pockets so I'm I'm
curious how the teaching of math has
changed as a result of that and whether
there will be further changes like you
know like as long as someone has a grasp
of basic algebraic principles uh do they
actually need to know how to do division
in their head you know what I mean yeah
um and I wonder
I wonder like how many skills people now
view as really crucial maybe a hundred
years from now we'll look back on and
say like oh that seems like mostly
obsolete because like we now have tools
that can do this for us and like I I
think arithmetic is going to go that way
uh cursive has largely gone that way
because like you can type faster than
you write in cursive most people have
laptops on them
I I heard something jarring uh again I
was talking to a school teacher who
teaches at the elementary school level
apparently kids these days many of them
are better at typing on their phone than
on a computer and some of them actually
really struggle to type on a computer
because they are interesting yeah so
they they will actually ask if it's okay
if they write their first draft of a
paper for example basically as a note on
their phone that's wild which to me is
obscene like that sounds so insane but
but yeah I guess I type pretty fast with
like the swipe texting yeah do you do
you swipe or do you go letter by letter
ah come on I go letter by letter yeah
that's fair yeah um but anyway like so I
I think that
um you know if you put put it to someone
like hey maybe like
composition like writing skills might
not matter quite as much in the future
because as long as you can bang some
ideas out there like AI can kind of
flesh out the rest of the text
I think when that hits a lot of people's
ears they would immediately be
scandalized because it's like well
that's been such an important skill for
so long but I think back to
um like so if you read kind of social
commentary from around the time the
printing press came out which I'm sure
most people listening to this have uh it
was scandalous like it was very scary in
this same type of way because prior to
that like education was mostly just
memorizing stuff because the way
information was disseminated was either
like uh you know in in oral Traditions
just verbally passed down and you just
had to like memorize it or in the case
of like you know academics and
universities you know there might be
like two copies of a particular scroll
in existence and you know if you're
doing your your PhD in Divinity at the
University of Genoa and they have like a
particular scroll in Florence or
something you take a trip down to
Florence you read it you memorize it and
like that's what you use for your
academic work thereafter like you have
to have a pretty good memory of that in
your mind the rest of your life
otherwise you have to take another road
trip to Florence to read it again yeah
um and so when books were invented folks
were just like this is terrible like
this is gonna ruin all of the skills
necessary to become like a well-read or
like a well-rounded intellectual person
because like folks are gonna stop
memorizing everything and that's going
to be the downfall of us all and now we
look back on him it's like oh like books
seem to be fine so yeah I I am
interested to see what new like skills
and avenues for creativity like AI opens
up for us and what skills we now think
are absolutely crucial that we'll look
back on in 50 years and be like oh yeah
we don't we don't really need that
anymore yeah it it'll be cool to see how
that goes I agree
um so you want to go ahead and dive in
you got a segment for us yeah let's do
it so uh let's let's shift from talking
about art and literature into uh
I mean study design yeah let's get out
of our wheelhouse and try to address
some of these topics yeah
um so let's start this this SEC this
segment with a question so Eric if you
had to narrow it down to precisely one
thing like obviously it's more than one
thing but if you just had to say like
what one thing more than anything else
seems to be the primary mechanism of
muscle hypertrophy what what would you
say yeah so that would bring me back to
um there's a few like pretty in-depth
reviews about the mechanism of muscle
hypertrophy usually they narrow it down
to Mechanical tension muscle damage and
metabolic stress and I actually would uh
you know I I would say that mechanical
tension being the first one there that
that's the one I would go with
um if I had to pick one yeah so I I
agree with you I I think that's a great
answer and
with that context a paper was recently
published with a very provocative title
effective resistance training mainly
depends on mechanical activation of fast
twitch fibers and so uh what I want to
do in this segment is address
partially is that true but more so
does does the paper bearing that title
present us with adequate evidence to
believe that it's true yeah um and so uh
the short version just here up top not
not trying to leave people in suspense
is uh no I I don't think we should put
much stock if any in this particular
paper and the reason I want to talk
about this the reason I'm doing this
segment is I've started seeing this
paper going around I think it was
published about a month ago uh first
time it came across any of my timelines
was maybe like two weeks ago and within
the last week I've seen more and more
people sharing it talking about it
discussing it uh and it's not it's not
big yet it's kind of like simmering
below the surface but I'm concerned that
it will kind of reach a critical mass
and uh like a lot of folks will become
aware of it and uncritically accept its
findings as true uh and it's like a band
that plays the cooler bars in town and
when they have a gig a lot of people
show up but like they don't have a huge
record deal yet correct yeah yeah so
um yeah basically I
I think that this is a
a
paper with findings built on incredibly
shaky foundations that I don't think we
should put much stock in so I I want to
do this segment just to just to head
that off essentially cool
um and just as a general note
if you have shared this paper uh perhaps
uncritically
um I this isn't a call out segment I
don't I don't begrudge you for doing
that I certainly don't think less of you
for doing that
um because like the the title of the
paper and its purported findings do seem
to track well with things we already
know mechanical tension seems to be very
important for hypertrophy so a people's
a paper saying mechanical activation of
fast twitch fiber seemed to be the
primary driving factor of hypertrophy
that seems to comport well with what we
already know and you know if things
already confirm what you know or
strongly suspect to be true you might be
a little bit less likely to look into it
deeply
um and also like I I do think that
there's just sort of a general Zeitgeist
around trying to find like a grand
unified theory of hypertrophy and that
sort of thing is just kind of like
intrinsically appealing to people and
the other reason I don't begrudge folks
for taking this paper on critically is
this study and also kind of the study
it's built upon
are very math heavy like extremely math
heavy and
so like I I'm the type of sick [ __ ]
who's willing to look at that and be
like oh okay let's let's put all of
these equations in a spreadsheet kind of
work through them see what's going on
here but like I totally get that if
someone either doesn't have a strong
math background or is just like a normal
person with plenty of things to do in in
a day you just see more than like three
Greek letters in a block of text and say
nope [ __ ] it like I'm I'm just gonna
trust that the authors did everything
right because it's not worth my time to
get into this
um so yeah uh if I can make a quick
comment before you dig into the details
here I don't mean to grab the steering
oh yeah but go for it I really like the
way that you it was a very subtle thing
but the way that you uh kind of alluded
to confirmation bias there where where
basically it seems to comport well with
kind of how you generally view things
and so you just kind of uncritically say
yeah that that works that makes sense
and you roll with it I think a lot of
people believe deep down that like
confirmation bias is a malicious Act of
cherry picking and that like when
someone is committing confirmation bias
or or expressing it they're like digging
in and saying how can I prove myself
right despite contradictory evidence but
I think the more
um uh the more damaging version of
confirmation bias is just that thing
where you say it's not that I'm like
maliciously cherry picking but like
because this comports with what I would
expect I'm simply not going to
scrutinize it with that same level of
intensity oh yeah for sure and I mean I
a hundred percent do that as well it's a
natural that's why it's a term it's a
time saving mechanism yeah yeah like if
a paper comes across the journal sweep
and it's like hey it's a high low
training versus low low training and
we're looking to see which one has a
larger effect on 1rm strength oh the
high load training did cool like I'm not
going to look into that paper in detail
and say like yeah does this finding hold
up because it's like well I I know or at
least so strongly suspect that to be
true I don't care that much about the
details like I'm just gonna put another
tally in the Hilo training is better
column you know and there's a
considerable degree of redundancy in our
our field oh yeah and I kind of chuckled
because I was thinking about like you
know a paper comes across and says yeah
creatine made people a little stronger
am I really gonna be like well I need to
email the author because I can't find
supplementary table number three correct
yeah it's just you you file it away and
say yeah that makes sense correct yeah
so to be clear what I'm arguing here is
not that mechanical activation of fast
twitch fibers aren't a predictive factor
for hypertrophy what I'm arguing is this
is not the study do you you should rely
on to make that point yeah all right so
um at this point if you're if you're
watching on YouTube we can just flash
the or we can just put the the abstract
up here because I think that's the part
of the study that most people have
actually read at this point uh and for
people listening I'm just going to read
the abstract just so we can all kind of
get our feet wet and understand the
sorts of claims that this paper is
making uh so the abstract says this
study conducted a secondary survey based
on the hypothesis that quote total
mechanical activation of fast twitch
fibers and the muscles determines the
effects of muscle hypertrophy close
quote with resistance training of the
knee extensor muscles as the Target
because of its importance in preventing
sarcopenia using a mathematical model
that estimates the mechanical activation
of each muscle fiber parentheses fast
twitch and slow twitch fibers close
parentheses during exercise which was
developed in a previous study we
estimated the total mechanical
activation of fast twitch 5 fibers and
30 training programs described in 23
selected previous studies on leg
extension exercise programs and their
muscle hypertrophy effect with the
estimated value and other factors of the
training effect described in previous
studies training volume Etc as
explanatory variables and muscle
hypertrophy effect as an objective
variable We performed multiple
regression analysis the results revealed
that the training effect was related to
Total mechanical activation of the fast
twitch fibers training load and number
of sets with the beta coefficients being
positive for mechanical activation of
fast twitch fibers and training load and
negative four number of sets
going on the total mechanical activation
of fast twitch fibers was the strongest
determinant of the muscle hypertrophy
effect not one quote right there as an
aside that one quote right there I think
is the thing people are are really
focusing on going on in addition we
predicted the relationship between the
level of the training effect of leg
extension exercise and program variables
this study is the first to demonstrate
quote the relationship between total
mechanical activation of fast twitch
fibers and muscle hypertrophy effect
close quote in the field of muscle
physiology and the first to elucidate
the association between the program
variables and the training effect so
just in layman's terms to break all of
that down what they did for this study
is they went through the literature they
didn't do a truly systematic literature
search essentially they they developed
some key terms and just just looked at
the hundred like the first hundred
studies with those key terms in them and
looked for the ones uh where there was a
longitudinal knee extension training
intervention with you know all of the
information they would need to apply
their model to it and they identified 23
such studies and the hundred results
they screened with 30 different training
protocols that assessed hypertrophy over
time once they found those studies and
those protocols they used a mathematical
model that they'd previously developed
to estimate total fast twitch fiber
activation during each protocol so
that's like that's an integrated effect
sort of area under the curve and then
from there they performed multiple
regression analysis to see which
training variables were were predictive
of hypertrophy responses and what they
found is that the strongest best
predictor was total mechanical
activation of fast twitch fibers which
was positively associated with
hypertrophy and then the other thing
people seem to be pulling out of this I
think erroneously is that in their
multiple regression model there was a
negative beta coefficient for
um
for number of sets like total training
volume and people are using this to
argue like ooh like
everyone's wrong about the effect of
training volume on muscle growth there's
a negative beta coefficient here if you
do more volume that leads to less growth
but with multiple regression that that's
basically saying when you hold like when
accounting for the other variables in
the model this seems to be negatively
predictive and so essentially total
activation of fast twitch fibers is
positively associated with training
volume because it's like a cumulative
metric like an area under the Curve
Metric and so essentially that negative
beta coefficient is telling you that the
additive effect of each additional set
is smaller and smaller so just to make
that clear
um but yeah anyway that's that's kind of
the the Layman
that was a pretty poor layman's terms
breakdown but that's that's sort of the
the grand
concise overview yeah that's that's the
general overview of the study
and like I said I think the part that
jumped out to most people when they were
were reading that abstract was just kind
of the core kind of flashy finding there
in the abstract that total mechanical
activation of fast twitch muscle fibers
was predictive of hypertrophy the thing
that jumped out at me was uh
this sentence specifically using the
mathematical model that estimates the
mechanical activation of each muscle
fiber uh fast twitch and slow twitch
which was developed in in a previous
study so you know they weren't using
studies that had measured mechanical
activation of fast twitch muscle fibers
they were using a set of equations to
estimate that variable and so that was
the thing that jumped out at me uh and
the reason that jumped out at me is that
I didn't think we could do that
particularly well
um for for a couple of reasons one is
that there aren't that many Labs that
can actually measure that variable so if
you're interested in looking at the
actual like Recruitment and activation
patterns of different fiber types you
need a very particular EMG setup like
high density EMG that you can use to
decompose the signals and look at
individual fibers which you can then
split out by fiber type and there aren't
that many Labs that can do that that
type of research and I also think we're
kind of a long way from being able to do
that type of research with Dynamic
exercise like you know eccentric and
concentric knee extensions because for
high density EMG to get good signals
that you can decompose and look at the
individual fibers I think you need to do
isometric exercise because you know the
electrodes are on the skin and as the
the muscle contracts like the position
of the individual fibers relative to the
skin moves a little bit
and so I think you have to do this only
with isometric exercise so like that
part jumped out at me when I was reading
the abstract because I was like oh like
that's that's actually incredibly cool
like if there's a a high quality
validated uh equation or set of
equations to be able to predict
um like fast twitch and slow twitch
fiber activation in Dynamic exercise
with any any reasonable degree of
granularity that's
if that exists like that's that's a
pretty big deal uh and I didn't know
that existed so I I was like okay let's
look at the paper that they're saying uh
like validated that equation uh and so
to be clear
the the main paper I'm talking about
here effective resistance training
mainly depends on mechanical activation
of fast twitch fiber like that paper
its findings rest solely on the
validation study at citing like because
their their data like their their
predicted data for fast twitch fiber
activation for their main study
like that all came from the equations
developed in the prior study they're
citing to which if you want to check all
of this out in the main paper it's
citation 20 you can pull it up for
yourself and so if the the paper they're
citing to if it shows good strong data
to say like hey based on these variables
we can predict fast twitch fiber
activation very well then this might be
a good reliable robust finding if we
look at this validation study and it
doesn't seem to predict fast twitch
fiber activation particularly well or
heaven forbid if that's not even what
that study was doing in the first place
uh you know maybe we're dealing with a
house built on Sand here so I pulled up
the validation study the title was
proposal and validation of mathematical
model for resistance training and before
I get into this uh Eric
can you just describe to me how
validation studies tend to work in our
field
yeah so you know there's different types
of validity and therefore different
types of validation studies
um I didn't do any equation validation
in my PhD we would normally do
validation for instruments and that's
pretty straightforward you're pretty
much comparing to a gold standard
Criterion measurement and saying hey how
close did we get
um but generally speaking when you're
trying to develop and validate an
equation you need to recruit a sample
that's theoretically representative of
the population you're trying to validate
this in and derive the predictive
equation so you measure some data you
measure the outcome of Interest
basically say okay which of these
predictors and in what combination
do we get a good you know predictive
equation that that describes or explains
the variance in that outcome right
and that's the first step but if you
bring in any sample of people you you
can get an equation right things vary
and therefore you will get an equation
if you really want one yes the point
where it becomes validation is when you
say you know what
the equation we got from these
individuals also works with other
samples of individuals from this
population yes so transferring those
values because you will get values
transferring those to other samples
effectively and reliably is where the
magic happens right so the the two
things there is one uh
you want you want to recruit a
representative sample and you also
generally want it to be a large enough
sample that you can have
reasonable reasonable confidence that
the equations you derive the findings
you get will generalize to the broader
population yeah and two
um
generally and I think always you want to
actually measure the thing you're trying
to predict yeah so for example if you
were trying to make a new body
composition equation you might have
people do a four compartment body
composition assessment and then look at
their maybe age lean mass sex maybe
activity level just whatever like any
number of things and then develop a set
of equations to see okay we've measured
their body composition we have this
other data can we use these other
variables to predict body comp which
which we measured and then you get
another sample in and say hey we measure
their body composition we collect this
other data does that set of equations
that I previously developed still
predict body comp pretty well in this
other sample okay so the but quite
notably there
you assessed body comp in both of those
samples right if that's the thing you're
trying to validate for so
when diving into this validation study
the first thing that jumped out at me is
there were only six subjects which
I mean maybe those are six subjects that
are incredibly representative of the
target population they were drawn from
and generally I'm not the the type of
person to uh like be such a nitpicker
about sample size but for for validation
studies like
you need more than that and that's six
subjects total that's not one population
of six subjects and then see if
equations hold up in another population
of six subjects it's just six subjects
which uh not a ton uh and then
uh the second thing that jumped out at
me and this is really the kicker they
didn't measure fast twitch fiber
activation in this study like they just
didn't uh like you can read the methods
for yourself this the both of these
studies I'm talking about full text is
free they'll be linked in the show notes
you can read this for yourself at no
point in the study did they actually
measure fast twitch fiber activation
they didn't even measure EMG like
nothing that was even like a proxy for
muscle activation at all and so if you
work your way through the study
ultimately what they were doing is they
were using quite a lot of complex math
to predict how many reps people would be
able to complete during sets to failure
with different loads at different
contraction velocities and with
different rest intervals and
how this worked is essentially they had
like 17 protocols they put these people
through and they looked to see whether
like they developed a set of equations
to predict uh how many reps they'd be
able to complete on subsequent sets of
like five set protocols with six of the
17 protocols and then they look to see
whether the equations they developed
from those six protocols could predict
uh reps to failure with the other 11
protocols with slightly different mixes
of training variables which you know is
a completely reasonable way to do a
validation study but again generally
you'd probably want more than six
subjects
um but like the important thing here is
this was not a validation study to see
if they could predict fast twitch fiber
activation it just wasn't
um what it was is there was one
particular equation in the set like in
the large set of equations they used
that contained assumptions about fast
and slow twitch fiber activation in
total fiber activation
um and it seems to be what they're doing
is saying well assumptions about fiber
activation were built in or kind of
baked into the equations we used the
equations we used seem to do a decent
job of predicting reps to failure
performance therefore all of the
assumptions baked into our equations
must therefore be true which
I don't know what else to say other than
that's not how that works yeah uh so uh
how a validation study for this might
look is that you could measure fast
twitch fiber activation during training
protocols in a group of subjects then
you develop a set of regression
equations based on get on data gathered
during those protocols to see if there's
a mix of variables that were predictive
of actual fast twitch fiber activation
then you put a new group of subjects
through those same training protocols uh
measure fiber act measure fast twitch
fiber activation as that new group of
subjects goes through these protocols
and then see whether the equations you
developed on that first population did
actually predict fast twitch fiber
activation in the second population
that's that's how you might do a
validation study to predict fast twitch
fiber activation from various like
training program characteristics that's
not what they did in their in their
validation and study to be clear like to
put this in no uncertain terms the
validation study they're citing was not
a validation study for predicting fast
twitch fiber activation it simply it
simply wasn't and I I don't know how
else to put it yeah so essentially the
the main paper I'm talking about here is
it's it's a house built on Sand like the
the data going into their model for
prediction of fast twitch fiber
activation from those 23 studies and 30
training protocols there is no reason to
suspect that they were accurately
predicting fast twitch fiber activation
in those 23 studies no reason whatsoever
yeah
um
and so uh
yeah I mean that's that's the bulk of my
critique uh it's this isn't a study to
to put
like any stock in whatsoever and I'll
also note just in Broad Strokes like if
you if you didn't want to get into all
of the nerd [ __ ] of actually going to
look at their supposed validation study
for this and and digging into it uh you
could just look at the text of the study
itself so there's uh and if you're
watching on YouTube we can we can Flash
an image up here
um like there's a figure just showing
the the bivariate relationship between
their predicted mechanical activation of
fast twitch fibers and increase in
muscle size and like
you can look at it for yourself there's
not much of a relationship there like in
in the two protocols with the lowest
predicted mechanical activation of fast
twitch fibers not much hypertrophy
occurred and then there's one like one
study where like in absurd amount of
hypertrophy occurred that did also have
a high predicted amount of mechanical
activation of fast twitch fibers but
beyond those like three data points
everything from like the the y-axis or
the x-axis here goes from like 200 to
1600 everything from like 500 to 1600
looks basically the same like you could
just draw a straight line through that
data like just just pure visual
inspection tells you that there's not a
particularly strong relationship there
um
and if that's not enough going an
additional step deeper like the actual
model they developed in their supposed
validation study also just conflicts
with experimental evidence in this area
so
I got another question for you Eric so
yeah let's hear it you're a bodybuilder
uh two sport professional bodybuilder
yeah I'm a bodybuilder but I more think
of myself as a classic bodybuilder yeah
that's fair but I mean you you are a pro
at both correct the Bo Jackson a
bodybuilding many people are saying so
you know you know a thing or two about
building muscle and how you might
personally train to go about trying to
build muscle
and so you know let's say you wanted to
do some low load training for for any
number of purposes maybe you just want a
bit of masochistic fun maybe you're
trying to train around or through an
injury and you can't load a joint
particularly heavy and and you have two
options on the table you can either do
three all-out sets of 30 reps with a
load that you can only do 30 reps with
so so three sets to failure 30 reps per
set really getting after it or
alternately you could do nine sets of 10
reps with the same load a load that you
could do 30 reps with with nice long
rest intervals per Set uh and you know
you're equating the number of reps
you're doing it's 90 reps regardless uh
the same load yeah with the same load
but it's three sets of 30 versus nine
sets of ten which one of those protocols
do you think you would derive a a
stronger growth stimulus from I would
expect the the three sets of 30. yeah so
I I would as well but again like so this
is something else we've talked about on
the podcast before like
when you're evaluating research are are
you signing actually maybe we maybe this
was a mass audio thing uh the thing
about eating fruit and whether that
makes you gain or lose 20 pounds or
whatever yeah uh anyways
um yeah so we we've talked about like
are you willing to take the results of
the study literally or not and if you're
willing to cite this paper and say hey
this is this is proof that uh mechanical
activation of fast twitch fibers is the
predictive factor of hypertrophy
if you're willing to do that and you're
you're signing on to this this is a
literal finding that we should take
seriously then you are implicitly
signing on to the study they're citing
for predicting fast twitch fiber
activation and when you look into that
that that would lead you to the point
where you would then therefore have to
argue that the nine sets of ten would be
a better hypertrophy stimulus which I
don't think many people would want to
like I don't I don't think many people
are going to carry water for that idea
so and if I could just contextualize
that you mentioned the fruit study
basically there's a study indicating
there's two different groups one group
they're like hey try to eat like a
little more fruit and that's the entire
intervention yeah the other group
they're like hey have a little bit less
fruit and that's the entire intervention
and they ended up having like a 30 pound
Gap in weight change over like the six
month trial and my my argument was like
no one actually believes this yeah like
no one literally believes that to be
true yeah
so the the model that they developed in
their previous study with assumptions
about fast and slow twitch fiber
activations baked in their model
essentially assumes that fast twitch
fiber activation progressively decreases
due to fatigue which is probably true
like that is potentially and and maybe
even likely one of the reasons why uh
training with really short rest
intervals is maybe less productive for
hypertrophy than slightly longer rest
intervals as fatigue accumulates uh
fiber recruitment might drop off a
little bit
um their model also assumes that fast
twitch fiber activation doesn't increase
as the set progresses and again if
you're watching on YouTube there's a
figure from that validation study that
we can put up here this is figure three
uh A and B so it shows uh predicted uh
fast twitch and total fiber activation
during sets with 80 percent of 1rm and
like it
like if you're watching this on YouTube
you can just look at it if you're
listening I can describe it to you
essentially it's showing predicted fast
twitch fiber activation in a over nine
reps and it is not changing rep to rep
to rep uh like it's a a solid a solid
line and the predicted fast twitch fiber
activation for each rep is the same as
the one before it and then B is the same
prediction but for the last set of an
exercise and uh yeah it's the same like
the predicted fast twitch fiber
activation is the exact same for every
single rep so it's
and that does conflict with uh
experimental evidence and also like the
best theoretical models we have of fiber
activation like it seems that as you get
closer to failure
um you recruit more of your higher
threshold motor units and uh like the
the uh
the the depolarization rate of your
highest threshold motor units increase
as you get closer to failure so that one
like their their model does seem to
conflict in that way with experimental
results
um
and their model essentially predicts
that the total uh like integrated area
under that curve is what is predictive
of hypertrophy and so essentially what
that signs you up to believe is that the
earliest reps in a set are just as
stimulating for hypertrophy as the later
reps in a set there's there's no
difference between those reps and the
activation of fast twitch fibers does
decrease as fatigue accumulates so you
don't want to go to failure and you
don't want to have short rest intervals
you want to stay a long way from failure
and have nice long rest intervals so you
don't accumulate fatigue and fast twitch
fiber activation stays high so if you
take this model seriously
like you're you would be saying nine
sets of ten at a 30 RM load is better
for hypertrophy than three sets of 30.
at a 30 RM load like that's like like
with 30 sets of three be even better
potentially so which again like I I
don't think anyone would actually argue
for in the real world but if if you're
taking this model seriously you have to
be willing to argue for that because
that is a logical implication of this
model that you're putting your weight
behind yeah
um and so like that
also just like conflicts with
longitudinal hypertrophy research we
have so there was a paper by uh
lasavikius and colleagues in 2019 called
muscle failure promotes greater muscle
hypertrophy and low load but not high
load training and it was essentially a
study looking at at this scenario we're
describing so there were four conditions
here uh two high load two low load
conditions uh two of the conditions
subjects just performed three sets to
failure and in the other two so a high
load to failure condition a low load to
failure condition and then the other two
groups one high load one low load group
they did five sets with sixty percent of
the number of reps as the to failure
condition so uh essentially if you
completed 80 total reps across three
sets to failure and the low load
condition you would do uh five sets of
16 to equate the total number of reps so
it would be sixty percent the number of
reps per set for sixty percent more sets
so it all works out or
66 whatever like you you get what I'm
saying yeah uh or if someone did like
three sets of ten to failure in the high
load condition 30 total Reps for the
non-failure condition they would do five
sets of six reps to equate uh and so in
that study if if you were taking this
model literally and seriously you would
predict that the non-failure conditions
would cause at least as much hypertrophy
as the failure conditions if not more uh
and what they did in fact actually find
and if you're watching this on YouTube
we'll we'll put the results up on the
screen the two high load conditions
caused the same amount of hypertrophy so
the failure and non-failure condition
both LED to similar muscle growth and
then for the low load conditions the
failure condition led to considerably
more muscle growth than than the
non-failure condition so again if you
were taking this model seriously that
would this finding would fully conflict
with that model it should be better to
do the low load training further from
failure so you don't accumulate as much
fatigue so fast twitch fiber activation
stays higher that is not what we see in
the actual experimental research so uh
just to recap the equations used in this
study to predict fast twitch fiber
activation haven't actually been
validated for predicting fast twitch
fiber activation and this whole segment
could could have just ended there like
that that wouldn't be any fun though
yeah that's that's enough to completely
obsolete the uh the main study I'm
talking about here
um but then also like The Logical
implications of the model that this is
all based on uh conflict with
experimental data and also just real
world experience like no no one would
actually train in the way that it is
suggested you should train if you take
this model seriously yeah uh so that's
all I've got and apologies if
this segment came across as too mean or
too harsh but like I said this this
study seems to be starting to gain a
foothold and I just think it would be a
real shame if if it kind of entered the
public Zeitgeist and folks were being
like Oh yeah like this is this is really
solid stuff we know what is predict like
we know what's causing hypertrophy based
on this study because
you just shouldn't you shouldn't draw
that conclusion from it like it's it's
not uh
like not to be too harsh but like it's
it's just not good work yeah
um and so yeah like I
you know I think there's value in
debunking misinformation that's already
out there and I also think there's value
in debunking misinformation before it
starts to take off and that's that's
what I'm trying to do here yeah no I
think you did a great job and I think
it's it's really important when you're
looking at a new study
um and you have access to the full text
just a couple quick things to prevent
from being led totally astray by some of
the chatter on social media
look at what actually got measured uh
look at not just the direction of
results but the actual magnitude and
then ask yourself in a very literal way
do I believe that yeah and like I I know
it sounds overly simplistic but if you
just you know use that as your just
entry point into a paper as like the
basic bare minimum of interpretation
it'll actually get you pretty far yeah
and that was one of the things I I don't
know if I misspoke when explaining the
the intervention with that fruit paper
but one group uh just had a tiny
increase in Fruit intake the other had a
tiny decrease and the researchers were
saying oh what happens to body weight
Greg you are familiar with fruit right I
am yeah what happens is nothing like
when you have when you have two more
pieces of fruit per day in a free living
situation you eat a little bit a little
less of something else and nothing
happens for the most part I mean I I did
a an experiment with my diet a while
back
precisely around that like I I was
consuming no fruit because I was doing a
bunch of meal prep and all of my carbs
for the day were already accounted for
mostly from rice and also a larger
percentage that I'm comfortable with
from onions I really like onions but
sometimes I eat so many onions I smell
like onions and that's probably less
than ideal so I was like hey let's let's
just mix things around and let's get rid
of all other carb sources I'm just
eating chicken and fruit yeah and so
like
if that study was to be taken literally
like the the group that increased fruit
consumption gained like 15 pounds the
group that decreased fruit consumption
lost like 15 pounds yeah so and we're
talking about a difference in Fruit
servings of like two or three plus or
minus a day or potentially even less
yeah so I I went from zero servings of
fruit per day to
I don't know exactly how they Quantified
it in that study but probably like 25
servings of fruit per day and like it
was fine uh yeah on net it seemed to be
productive but uh I just kind of got
tired of of cutting up all of that fruit
and also like I don't like going to the
store that often this was the biggest
thing like fruit goes bad and this this
isn't food safety advice audience they
tell you like food that you cook and
then you put in the fridge you should I
think they say that it's only like safe
to eat for like four or five days
that's a lie it's good for up to like a
week and a half
that I don't take that seriously I'm not
saying that as an expert that's not
advice to you me personally up to a week
and a half I'm like okay this is fine
whatever I've never gotten sick from it
yeah anyway fruit goes bad after like
three or four days so I I went from
going to the store once per seven to ten
days to go into the store like every two
days I was like ah this is just annoying
but in terms of body composition effects
it was entirely unremarkable yeah and if
if anything not not to give too much of
a spoiler there is some research kind of
hinting at the idea that when you add
fruit to your diet and you don't change
anything else and you're in a free
living situation you might even reduce
your caloric intake to offset that uh
you you might end up with a net
reduction in calorie intake if you
replaced kind of low satiety food
sources with fruit right so if you went
from like a sugary beverage to in to
increasing fruit intake adding that
fruit might actually induce just a tiny
bit of weight loss right so is that a
segue to the next section it is but uh I
have no idea how I'm going to address
editing those two things together that's
that's totally fine I can just put a
nice bow on my segment right here and we
can get into yours do it yeah so yeah
just to fully recap oh but wait I didn't
make the point I was trying to make the
point I was trying to make is again with
the people who were kind of sharing that
fruit study all over the place it's like
if the first thing they did was look at
the magnitude of weight change and just
ask themselves do you believe that
increasing your fruit by a couple
servings a day really is going to cause
you to gain 15 pounds and do you really
believe that reducing by a couple
servings a day is really going to cause
you to lose 15 pounds if all you did was
ask yourself that question you'd say no
and you'd shut your computer and walk
away yeah right but but it got all this
attention and no one bothered to ask
themselves do I believe this yeah yeah
but go ahead yeah so the the main point
I want to I want you to walk away with
is just in the context of this
particular study again title effective
resistance training mainly depends on
mechanical activation of fast twitch
fiber I am not arguing that that is
maybe even potentially not a true
statement who knows it could be the
point I'm making is that
you shouldn't rely on this citation to
make that point and if you see people
start to discuss this study start to
share it around maybe share this podcast
clip with them or if you do you know if
you uh aren't feeling uh generous and
wanting to give us the traffic uh just
ask them which they think would be
better for hypertrophy nine sets of 10
with a 30 RM load or three sets of 30.
and if they say oh it's got to be the
three sets of 30 say okay you don't
actually believe what this study is
saying
um and uh implore that they look at the
validation study it was based on and
asked them does the validation study
actually at any point measure fast
twitch fiber activation hopefully
they'll realize it doesn't and realize
uh maybe this isn't the study they
should rely on to make that point
sounds good to me yes sir all right you
ready to move on let's do it let's talk
speaking of fruit earlier let's talk a
little bit about nutrition okay so Greg
I want to uh put put a a hypothetical
scenario on the table and get your
perspective on this so let's say I'm
working with a dietitian who is
qualified to give me a full meal plan
and this dietitian that I'm working with
we have very ambitious goals we want to
try to kind of thread the needle and
Peak for two very different sports at
the same time maybe a professional
bodybuilding show and even something way
different like a professional classic
bodybuilding show okay so we're it's a
it's an ambitious protocol we're putting
together and they're helping me with my
fat loss as I prepare for these
competitions
and so they say Eric you're supposed to
have uh chicken and sweet potato for
this meal
and I say well I'm sick of this food I
can't I can't bear to eat more chicken
and sweet potato instead I want to have
some turkey and a white potato now I'm
gonna arrange them so that the the carbs
fat protein fiber hypothetically I'm
gonna make it all work
am I making an upgrade a downgrade or am
I going to be making the same exact
amount of progress moving forward
uh I think you'll probably make ooh well
it depends on the extent to which you
subscribe to the John Harbaugh School of
nutrition that's interesting um I think
the published research would tend to
suggest that you would probably make
about the same progress with both of
those approaches but
as we know chicken is a nervous bird and
maybe if you're trying to win you don't
want a bunch of chicken in your diet I
don't know where turkey fits on the
nervous bird hierarchy uh but for to
answer that question we we might need to
call in an expert they do
they do run if you get too close to them
in the forest like wild turkeys so they
might be nervous birds as well if if
they are conditional on that I would say
probably similar progress with both
approaches now my understanding is that
Benjamin Franklin wanted the turkey to
be the national bird of the United
States so that tells me that they've got
you know they're a little bit more
resilient a little bit tougher than a
chicken I would assume just in terms of
their uh you know their their
temperament and their composition yeah
but Ben Franklin also wasn't your
classic tough guy that's true but anyway
so
uh do you know the the uh the acronym i
i f y m stands for If It Fits your
Macros do you know where that came from
originally I thought it came from the
bodybuilding.com uh misc board but I
don't know if that's true so my
understanding I don't know the exact
area where it popped up I believe that's
correct but you know whatever I'm not
going to commit to it without doing the
research on it but the the general Vibe
the reason that this whole acronym came
to be is because people were on these
you know bodybuilding message boards
saying well I want to swap out this food
for that food I want to swap out that
food for the other food can I do this
and still succeed with my weight loss
goal or hypertrophy goal or whatever the
case is and people would say dude If It
Fits your Macros just do it it's fine if
you're equating your carb fat and
protein intake and in some cases your
fiber intake for the day as well uh
usually fiber they talk about across the
whole day not within an individual food
swap but if it fits the macro plan the
the carb fat and protein Target that
you're shooting for every day just do it
it's fine you're going to end up in the
same place and that uh you know that
whole idea of If It Fits your Macros the
more kind of formal term for that that
has gained popularity is flexible
dieting
and flexible dieting that the flexible
part pertains to flexibility with
regards to Food Source selection
basically the idea is flexible dieting
means you can choose whatever food
sources you prefer to hit your macro
Targets on a daily basis and make
totally satisfactory progress toward
your body composition goals and
flexible dieting or If It Fits your
Macros it is a valid concept it works
broadly speaking you know you are not
restricted to the like seven classic
bodybuilder Foods right so back in the
day when people started cutting they
would say oh I have to eat this very
rigid restrictive short list of foods
that bodybuilders just traditionally eat
it was a lot of white fish like tilapia
or tilapia I don't know how to say it
chicken breasts rice sweet potato
broccoli the whole deal uh there's a
classic video back in the day where
someone was prepping for a bodybuilding
show and like literally all he ate was
uh I think it was fish and rice cakes do
you ever see that video yeah
um but yeah so people are restricting
themselves to these very tiny food lists
and it was unnecessary right
so people with and this was a very
positive thing a net a net benefit here
for the bodybuilding world and the
fitness world uh collectively this idea
of flexible dieting If It Fits your
Macros this is valid and it works and
and it indicates that we have a lot of
flexibility for what food choices we
make what food sources we select to hit
our daily macro targets however there
has been a downside of you know this uh
this trend in which people have broadly
embraced that concept and I want to
demonstrate the downside by by sharing
two different statements so the first
statement is as follows
you have flexibility to select from a
wide range of food sources in accordance
with your goals and preferences there
are no foods that are fully off limits
for Fitness enthusiasts
that's a true statement that's good the
second statement food source selection
doesn't matter
a lot of people have transitioned from
the first sentence to the second the
first statement to the second
almost kind of implying equivalence and
the purpose of my my segment here is to
highlight the fact that those are two
very different statements and what I'm
trying to get at here is
when it comes to food source selection
you can pick from an almost Limitless
range of food sources that part of
flexible dieting I absolutely support
it's simply true
but I think a lot of times people try to
take that a step further and act like
food source selection is completely uh
meaningless like it has no impact on
your dietary progress and success and I
don't think that that is true because my
belief based on the research
is that food source selection is a
variable that we can strategically
leverage we can make food swaps uh
strategically to set ourselves up for a
diet that is basically going to set us
up for more success as we move forward
so before I get into that I want to give
a little bit of background information
about the regulation of food intake and
I'm just completely pulling this from a
really incredible guest article that we
had in the mass research review by Dr
Ann Catherine isolt and it was all about
the kind of
neurophysiological elements of food
intake regulation
so food intake as she explained in this
article is regulated by several
interrelated brain circuits and as I
talk through this I'm going to show some
images on the screen that kind of show
what these these circuits look like so
the first one is the hunger circuit uh
and there are of course a number of gut
derived hormones and hormones derived
from adipose tissue are produced by
adipose tissue that work their way up uh
into the hypothalamus and relay signals
about the regulation of hunger there's
also the satiety circuit uh and what we
see is that the satiety circuit involves
a number of different brain structures
that are they're all in the the
hypothalamus and hindbrain regions but
it's certainly a complicated circuit
with a lot of different brain structures
that are involved in this communication
and this regulation and there are a
number of peripheral structures that are
highly involved in that satiety circuit
as well also can I just say brain
circuits sound like stuff out of sci-fi
yes like arcuate nucleus ventral
tegmental area
dorsal striatum like that that all that
all sounds like places in like a Sci-Fi
City or something absolutely yeah the
brain stuff gets serious but the third
uh brain circuit that I want to talk
about here is the consumption circuit
this is another one where the
hypothalamus is heavily involved and it
includes reward responses to hyper
palatable food okay so uh we've got
hunger satiety and then this consumption
circuit uh which involves the reward
centers in our brain and specifically
how they relate to the consumption of
food that's hyper palatable or just
really really really tasty and gives us
this uh this really nice sensation of
reward when we consume them so another
brain structure that's involved here
which is a little bit simpler is the
prefrontal cortex and uh the prefrontal
cortex is heavily involved with Goal
directed behavior and impulse control so
the prefrontal cortex the hypothalamus
the hind brain we've got all these
different brain structures and areas
that are working together conveying
different signals but you know they're
they're integrating all of this
peripheral information so that we can
kind of control our food intake and
there's this kind of give and take
between these different systems right
now the reason that I bring that up uh
this kind of integrated control of
feeding is because uh it it's pretty
important when we talk about uh swapping
out food sources right so let's say that
you are weighing one carb Source versus
another or one protein Source versus
another a lot of people like to reduce
that and basically say well you know
carbs or carbs protein is protein right
so when we talk about food sources and
how they impact hunger and satiety one
of the most common questions people ask
is uh you know are carbs more satiating
than fats or is protein more satiating
than carbs a lot of people like to break
it down simply into macros and there's
some utility of that but I think that's
the wrong question to ask when it comes
to how is this food going to actually
influence my feeding behaviors my actual
food intake because there are all these
different brain structures that are kind
of conveying all these different
messages and and communicating with one
another to collectively modulate energy
intake so a lot of times with satiety or
regulation of intake people want to make
it just a question about macro content
and I think that's the wrong question to
be asking it's not irrelevant but it's
way too superficial to really get to the
the root of what you're trying to figure
out here when you're weighing one food
source versus another so things you want
to ask yourself are these two different
food sources that I'm comparing do they
impact my brain's reward system to the
same extent and things that are going to
play into that would be the aroma the
flavor the mouth feel of the food the
ease of consumption other contextual
factors that will influence your
experience your subjective experience of
consuming that food are they going to
impact satiety to the same extent of
course macronutrient breakdown plays a
role but normally with food swaps we're
talking about meals that we kind of
assume the macro content is going to be
relatively equated in this context but
we want to look at things like what is
the mass of this meal what is the volume
of the meal the texture the rate of
consumption the fiber content the water
content the energy density which of
course is kind of tied in with several
of those elements and then also when
we're when we're comparing two different
food sources we might ask ourselves do
these food sources actually play the
same role within the meal and interact
with other Foods the same way you know
there are some foods that kind of make
us want to consume more of a different
food because they go really well
together and there are other foods that
we could put it in a meal and it would
not have that same effect you know
there's almost a bit of synergy where
certain food pairings we say those two
together those make it really hard to
put the spoon down right so there's a
lot that goes into potential food swaps
I think a good example of that because I
I think that may come across as like
abstract to some folks yeah but I think
a good example of that is if someone is
really into eating chicken wings yeah
like the carrots and celery that come
with the chicken wings are just kind of
like to give your your mouth a break
just from the The Heat Of The Wings to
kind of cool cool off so you can go in
with more wings so it's like
theoretically like you know if you get
an order of 20 wings and that's all you
could eat maybe you might want to only
eat 10 or maybe a dozen of them before
you're just like oh this is just it's
salty vinegary spicy like I'm kind of
done with this you know but then if you
can kind of cool off with a little
celery maybe dipped in some blue trees
dressing you're like ooh this is nice
little flavor contrast texture contrast
cool the mouth down you know it would be
good some more fatty spicy vinegary
salty chicken wings yeah so yeah yeah
and one that comes to mind for me
um
is a really simple one but uh the idea
of having coffee versus green tea so in
a vacuum I enjoy both of them very much
but when I drink coffee sometimes I say
you know what would go great with this
something chocolatey or maybe a pastry
or something sweet or kind of like a
creamy like dessert type of thing uh
when I drink green tea this could
totally be uh just my perspective
I don't think a lot of foods go
particularly well with green tea or at
least not a lot of foods that I consume
regularly so if I drink green tea I can
say this is a lovely cup of tea and I
don't want anything else yeah this is
great but when I drink coffee I do start
to want something that's sweet or
chocolatey or something like that and so
it's one thing where a little beverage
swap can really make a big difference
about what other Foods you might
gravitate toward you know or if I was
eating something that goes well with
coffee if I was going to end my meal
with coffee
maybe I'm more likely to actually
continue that meal and eat even more
yeah you know versus if I had some tea
after that meal and it was just a clear
signal okay meals over we're on to a
completely different set of flavors here
right so so that's what I'm getting at
is the fact that when we talk about
making a food swap it's not just about
if the macros equate we have to consider
a broader picture of how all these
different brain structures communicate
with one another and regulate food
intake
um and you know a great example like I
said the the prefrontal cortex is
heavily involved with Goal directed
Behavior one of the things that can be
really helpful with food source
selection is if we don't necessarily
have to work too hard to kind of you
know so if you eat a lot of really hyper
palatable meals that for you are just a
10 out of 10 on the flavor scale yeah
you're like this is incredible every
time the meal ends it's a tragedy you
are really pushing yourself to weigh
this massive reward response versus goal
directed behavior and there's this tug
of war that you are really amplifying by
doing that and so one of the things when
your internal dialogue is Guy Fieri's
external Dialogue on Diners Drive-Ins
and Dives you might you might run into
issues exactly and so again we can
strategically leverage that and say you
know what if I dropped from a meal that
for me is just a 10 out of 10 in terms
of palatability and I went to like a
seven out of ten and it was still a very
nice meal but I can be done with it and
not just feel absolutely distraught that
the meal's over that can be a really
helpful thing when dieting so when I
transition to a fat loss phase I do
something that some people view as
counterintuitive but I actually go
toward foods that are slightly less
palatable rather than trying to say okay
I only have 2 100 calories today how do
I make that as palatable as possible
which a lot of people do and for frankly
I kind of think they'd be better off if
they didn't go that route so what I'm
getting at here is
Foods contribute a lot more than their
macros not just in terms of like
micronutrients and stuff like that but
also in how they impact our body's
systems that regulate food intake and
that means uh you know we have to look
at food sources and consider more than
just you know making the macros fit
there's a lot more that goes into it
when it comes to regulation of food
intake so what I want to do is look at a
couple studies that have said okay let's
actually put this to the test so let's
not just say Okay protein is more
satiating than carbs so if you want to
be satiated eat more protein let's look
at actual Foods
and see how they impact subjective
satiety levels and also how much people
tend to eat after the meal or in
combination with that food right so the
first paper paper I want to look at is a
classic by Holt and colleagues in 1995
if you've ever heard of the satiety
Index this is where it originated what
they did was they gave uh servings of 1
000 kilojoules which is uh 240
kilocalories or Capital C calories uh
they looked at 38 different foods split
into six different food categories so
fruits Bakery products snack foods
carbohydrate-rich Foods protein rich
foods and breakfast cereals and they fed
these servings to these individuals in
the study and looked at their satiety
ratings over the next
120 Minutes or two hours and what I'm
going to show on the screen is is the
general finding here what they did was
they they made white bread the kind of
standard score of a hundred percent so
all of these were framed as a satiety
index score as a percentage in
comparison to white bread so anything
over a hundred percent was more
satiating than white bread and anything
under a hundred percent was less
satiating than white bread again giving
a 240 calorie uh serving of all these
different foods in isolation and so
generally speaking when you look at the
satiety index it was a really great
piece of research a very valuable thing
that was contributed uh the general
pattern was that foods with uh low
energy density
high fiber content high water content
those were generally foods that in a
vacuum lent themselves to Greater
satiety responses and that's pretty
straightforward and it kind of conforms
with you know what most people consider
to be kind of diet foods when you go on
a diet and you're trying to reduce
calorie intake without starving all day
people do tend to gravitate toward these
types of foods so this was a great piece
of research but there was a shortcoming
in the sense that this paper has low
ecological validity it's not very
representative of real world eating
scenarios because it's not very often
that we say ah I think I'm going to sit
down and have 240 calories of white
bread and nothing else yeah or I'm gonna
sit down and have 240 calories of white
potatoes with absolutely nothing else
right so
what's really interesting is you know
looking at research that kind of builds
upon this and says well in the context
of a regular diet in a free living
individual who's eating meals with food
combination combinations that they
selected uh over the course of a real
day in their normal life what foods seem
to be associated with greater or lesser
energy intake broadly speaking so I want
to talk about a paper by Horgan and
colleagues and that's exactly what they
were looking at so
rather than looking at a controlled
feeding Sim uh scenario with a single
isolated food they said let's look at
all of your food records over a four day
period and they had uh 6 000 four day
diet records that were completed by a
ton of people over in the United Kingdom
and they were looking at you know if we
sort these different foods into 60
distinct categories
How does each of these food categories
influence overall energy intake and I am
going to show some figures that don't
contain 60 categories because that would
be a really big figure so not all
categories are represented Within These
figures but they did sort these into a
total of 60 categories and they looked
at this two different ways which is
really cool and really valuable this was
a very insightful way to look at it they
looked at how these different food
categories influenced energy intake both
within individuals and between
individuals
So within individuals they're basically
looking at how changing your intake of a
particular food influences your kind of
day-to-day fluctuation and energy intake
so on the days you ate more of this food
you ate fewer calories you know and vice
versa uh they also looked at between
individual uh differences so in this
case they were looking at the people who
eat more of this food seem to eat fewer
calories than the people who eat less of
this food right so that's kind of how
you frame these two different uh ways of
looking at the data between individuals
and within individuals so on the screen
right now you're going to see what they
call the compensation coefficient
between individuals and generally
speaking the lower this this value is or
the more negative the more it leads to a
reduction in energy intake I know that's
kind of a weird way to frame it but you
could I don't want to use satiety
incorrectly here because that's not not
strictly what it is but when you have a
low coefficient it basically means the
you know the people who eat more of
these low coefficient Foods tend to eat
less than the people who are eating more
High coefficient Foods that's kind of
the the very basic surface level
interpretation so if you were going to
be for example choosing foods that would
help you reduce your energy intake very
passively you would want to be selecting
foods with a low coefficient right and
so you can kind of look at these and I'm
going to give a broad summary so people
are just like looking through you know
dozens of categories here I'm also going
to display the uh the data here for the
uh the coefficients within individuals
so again just looking at the data a
slightly different way and what you see
is generally speaking there's you look
at the top of these figures with some of
these low coefficient food groups skim
milk a lot of high fiber breakfast
cereals fruit things like that stuff
that's generally uh you know have some
pretty similar characteristics that I'll
get into but one of the things that's
really fascinating when you look through
this is there's a lot of variability a
lot of noise in the data from food to
food it's not like the first three are
all vegetables and then the second three
are all fruits and then the next you
know it's not neatly categorized in the
way you would expect and there are some
some uh some foods that kind of surprise
you a little bit right so uh for example
smoothies end up being a really high
coefficient food whereas most people
would say hey you're putting some you
know some uh fruit maybe some vegetables
a little bit of yogurt in there with
some milk seems healthy enough to me
ends up being a really high coefficient
food uh one of the things that I I
thought was really funny was
man I've seen so much bad internet
content about
like oh man butter is so good for you
it's a superfood you should spread it on
everything
polyunsaturated fatty acids basically
poison stay away from them at all costs
I've seen other people saying no pufas
higher satiety per calorie you know
better from a cardio metabolic
standpoint definitely go with these
poofa based spreads these
polyunsaturated fat based spreads when
you look at it in the context of this
it's like man what a useless argument to
go down like in turn in terms of like
when people make arguments about like oh
all you have to do is swap your
margarine for butter and you're going to
reduce your energy intake or vice versa
yeah uh and when it when it comes to
impacts on energy intake they're looking
pretty similar now different cardio
metabolic effects for sure I don't want
to make it seem like they have
completely equivalent effects on blood
lipids that's not the case but that's a
discussion for a different time but uh
anyway if we look at the results in
paint with a broad brush like I said
there are some interesting uh instances
where like you know for example uh
specific alcoholic beverages might find
themselves in very different standings
in term terms of the the actual
coefficient there was a lot of
variability and a lot of noise when you
go from food to food and it didn't fit
into these like perfectly tidy bins that
you could categorize easily but a few
notable food categories with low
coefficients were foods that had low
energy density
foods with high fiber content and foods
that were artificially sweetened foods
and beverages I should say that were
artificially sweetened some things with
high coefficients again lending
themselves to higher total energy intake
in the day we're foods that generally
tended to be very snackable but just
based on the context in which they're
normally eaten alcoholic beverages
generally but not in all cases spreads
that you might put on a bread-based
product so like butter margarine Jam
jellies they were all pretty high
coefficient things and that's to be
expected based on the context in which
they're consumed and then full sugar
beverages were definitely a high
coefficient category and we could kind
of lump smoothies into that because a
lot of commercially prepared smoothies
do tend to be quite high in sugar a lot
higher than most people anticipate yeah
um so one thing I want to mention here
is that I'm not saying we should be
using this totally in place case of the
satiety index because you know it's not
a better or worse situation when we look
at these coefficients versus satiety
index values but these are two very
different ways of viewing the problem
right so
uh these coefficients they they have a
lot of ecological validity when we
compare them to the satiety index study
but this is observational data and I
know this is cliche but in this
particular scenario we have to be very
cautious about resisting the urge to
imply or infer causation based on
correlation so there might be a food
that just because of the context in
which it is routinely eaten it lends
itself to being lumped on like a high
energy intake day or mixed with high
energy intake Foods it may not be
because of a specific characteristic of
the food but more reflective of the
context in which it's consumed so uh the
Practical takeaway here from this study
you know in light of some of those
limitations or caveats the results
largely support the satiety promoting
effects of a dietary pattern that
features a lot of foods with low energy
density plenty of fiber and it also
reins enforces the utility of switching
from sugar beverage sugar sweetened
beverages to low calorie beverages that
are you know flavored with either
artificial or non-nutritive sweeteners
so things like uh you know monk fruit
extract Splenda sucralose those are the
same thing aspartame or your favorite
Stevia which I know you're a big Stevie
ahead
um completely untrue and you'll be
hearing from my lawyers that is slander
per se yes uh they're also uh I think
these findings give us kind of a
cautionary lesson which is you know we
really ought to be mindful of extra
calories that sneak in when for example
we're at an event where we're drinking
alcoholic beverages uh or you know in a
social environment or situation where uh
you know we're very likely to just have
high calorie snack food available being
very very conscious of calorie intake in
those situations can be helpful but I
think the results also mind us to focus
on broader eating patterns whereas the
satiety index kind of convinced people
to look at individual Foods in isolation
and ultimately you know looking at
broader eating patterns and kind of the
uh the entire Matrix of the meal and how
Foods put together and how eating one
food causes you to eat more of another
food that's a really important aspect
with food source selection that often
gets overlooked other noteworthy studies
on this topic of putting together meals
strategically there's one by Hall and
colleagues the title was Ultra process
diets cause excess calorie intake and
weight gain and inpatient randomized
controlled trial of AD libidum food
intake as you would guess based on the
title they found in the study that
processed foods are generally consumed
in excess for multiple different reasons
they're often consumed faster they have
a a lower effect on suppressing appetite
acutely and yeah there's a number of
characteristics of these highly Ultra
processed foods that broadly speaking
can lend themselves to higher energy
intakes along those lines there's a
study by tail Owen colleagues called
texture-based differences in eating rate
influence energy intake for minimally
processed and Ultra processed meals and
so basically what they found was they
didn't just look at the level of
processing with with meals but also the
texture of the meals and they found that
when people were given a soft and highly
processed meal they tend to eat eat more
quickly and generally eat more and when
we look at the literature looking at
meals that are harder in texture and
lower in their degree of processing
usually that's going to involve a little
bit more chewing we spend more time with
the the Aromas and the flavors of that
food it gives our satiety signals a
little bit more time to basically kick
in upon the onset of eating and so what
they found in this study is that eating
rate and energy intake were influenced
by not just the degree of processing but
also just the texture of the food again
again with hard textures and low degree
of processing generally promoting a
slower eating rate and less energy
intake there's also a study by Flynn and
colleagues that just came out very
recently where they were looking at what
actually sends the signal to kind of say
okay the meal's over let's shut it down
we're done eating and what's really
interesting is they looked at energy
density and they found that
changing the energy density of the of a
meal was very uh useful from a strategic
perspective but only to a point what
they found was if you can incorporate
some foods with low energy density
and energy density what we're talking
about there is the energy content in
kilocalories divided by the mass of food
in grams uh and like I said usually
foods with a lot of fiber content and
water content tend to be foods with low
energy density so you know fibrous
fruits and vegetables melons like
watermelon has really low energy density
uh most green leafy vegetables stuff
like that what they found uh was if
you're able to incorporate foods with
low energy density and get the energy
density of your meal in in its totality
down to like
1.75 or 2 kilocalories per gram at in
that particular scenario the volume of
food you're eating seems to be the
limiting factor that convinces you okay
meals over you've eaten plenty of just
bulk food content but when you get into
meals that have higher energy density so
we're talking about over like two and a
half three kilogram calories per gram in
that situation it's usually just the
calorie content of the meal that plays
the rate limiting role in determining
when it's time to stop eating so even if
you have this meal that's like five
kilocalories per gram like really high
energy density if you say hey I'm going
to put in a couple stalks of celery to
try to you know you know cut into that
energy density it's probably not going
to do much because it's going to bring
you down from 5 to 4.8 and and you're
still in that range where where calorie
intake is the dominant signal so
just to give some kind of practical
takeaways from the totality of this
literature
so that people can strategically
uh revisit their food source selection
uh number one regulation of energy
intake is really complex it's really
complicated and it comes down to a lot
more than macronutrient distribution so
it's absolutely true that flexible
dieting is an effective strategy it's
absolutely true that mixing in different
foods that fit your Macros will
absolutely keep you you know on the road
toward whatever goal you're pursuing you
know if you're still hitting your Macros
effectively but what what I'm trying to
indicate in this segment is that we can
make that job a little bit easier by
choosing food sources strategically such
that we are not working so hard to kind
of override these different signals
related to hunger satiety and Hyper
palatability and the way that affects
our reward control center so we can you
know If It Fits your Macros works it's
valid flexible dieting totally valid but
we can strategically quickly swap in
different food sources in a way that
really meaningfully impacts our ad
libidum energy intake or just our desire
to eat more when we're on a diet so
whether you're bulking or you're cutting
or you're maintaining I would encourage
people to consider a few factors when
they're selecting food sources number
one is energy density again high fiber
content high water content low mass uh
or you know looking looking at low
energy per unit of mass or volume in
that meal low energy density tends to be
really helpful if you're struggling with
Hunger if satiety is low and hunger is
high trying to have meals with low
energy density is very helpful and you
could look at two different meals with
the same macros but one has different
energy density that is going to
meaningfully influence your experience
as a Dieter both can get you where
you're going with your body comp goal
but one path can be a lot easier than
the other if you're struggling with
Hunger right and then if you're bulking
it goes the opposite direction
if you're like really struggling to get
enough calories in and you're eating a
bunch of really low energy density meals
you can strategically change that and
and go toward higher energy density
meals and potentially make the process a
little bit easier so I'm not saying that
you know flexible dieting doesn't work
I'm saying that we can still work on
that macro Target framework but make
these meals a little bit more compatible
with the way our body actually regulates
energy intake yeah uh other things you
want to keep in mind and again I want to
reiterate when you're talking about
energy density and really trying to
effectively leverage it some of this new
Research indicates you want to look at
meal level energy density not just
saying oh I'm going to bring some celery
with my cheesecake and that's going to
work out great right you want to try to
get the whole meal into that into that
range of being under like 1.75 or 2
kilocalories per gram other things
texture and level of processing again if
you're struggling dealing with hunger
and you want to boost satiety a little
bit harder texture lower level of
processing generally speaking that's
painting with a broad brush but you know
these are the kind of Trends and
patterns we see
foods that you're likely to consume
slower probably will help you know there
are some foods like for example if
you're eating nuts that you have to
crack each nut individually that's kind
of a unique way to slow down your eating
rate compared to just a big bowl of nuts
that are already pre-shelled or
pre-cracked right so there's some really
fun or interesting research where
they'll take the same damn food and just
find ways to make people eat it slower
and a slower rate of food intake can be
helpful when it comes to promoting
satiety like that uh like the classic
apple apple juice study yeah yeah there
is a study where they they had some
people drink apple juice and like just
out of a glass and other people eat it
like soup with a spoon and yes slowing
things down changing texture there's
also study Apple studies Apple where
related where they take a whole apple or
a mashed up Apple and the whole Apple
tends to be better for satiety than
mashing it up into a softer more
processed form
palatability again you want your meals
to taste good but maybe not absolutely
phenomenal when you're dieting because
that the way it lights up that reward
signal or that Reward Center of your
brain can actually override some of
those satiety signals and lead to some
degree of dysregulation of of the hunger
and satiety circuits and dysregulation
might be a strong word but you can
override satiety signals that would have
otherwise convinced you hey we're good
here we don't need to eat more yeah
that's that's like a distillation of the
comments saying like oh there's always
room for dessert yeah you know like you
could be stuffed but it's like ah little
bowl of ice cream Little Slice of
Cheesecake I can find room for that yeah
absolutely
um so yeah texture speed of consumption
palatability food combinations like I
said you might consider saying you know
what whenever I eat this I crave the
other so maybe I'm just gonna not eat
either of them and do a different food
swap that's going to be uh you know it's
gonna help me stay on track and not feel
like I have to work so hard and you so
much willpower to hit these macro
Targets on a daily Target uh and of
course anytime you're talking about food
source cost matters ease of preparation
matters uh cooking and storage you know
the feasibility of making the food and
having it when you need it that stuff
all matters and so like I said the thing
that's going to dictate your progress
toward your body composition goal your
Fitness goal of course a major major
element probably the most important
thing is your macro targets hitting the
right General amount of you know carbs
fats and protein every day and special
specifically your calorie intake and
your protein intake in most cases those
are the two numbers that are really
going to dictate your body composition
progress again under the assumption that
you're not like tremendously deficient
in micronutrients right so the whole
premise of setting macro targets and
really prioritizing those and using food
swaps that get you to those macro
targets completely valid and I'm not
trying to take away from that what I'm
trying to do is remind people you have a
really valuable tool in your pocket even
when you're doing flexible dieting or
this kind of If It Fits your Macros
approach you can strategically utilize
food swaps and substitutions and
leverage your food source selection in a
way that doesn't make your diet
necessarily more effective but makes
adherence easier and makes the process
subjectively much more enjoyable and it
can take you from a place where a
certain set of macro targets leaves you
hungry every night to a situation where
you actually feel uh you know like you
have a really high level of satiety your
hunger's under control and you feel like
you really don't have to exert too much
willpower to hit those Targets on a
daily basis so I would encourage people
if you're dieting whether it's you know
like I said weight gain weight loss
weight maintenance
revisit your food source selection with
all of these factors in mind and ask
yourself is there a way that I can
strategically alter my food source
selection not to make my diet more
effective but to make it more feasible
more enjoyable more in line with my
preferences and to help me regulate my
hunger and satiety cues more effectively
makes sense to me
all right anything else for this episode
or can we wrap up here I think we can
wrap up all right sounds good
um well that does it for this show as
always thank you so much for joining us
and we will be back soon with another
episode of The Stronger by science
podcast
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules we
hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
can sign up for the free newsletter at
strongerbuyscience.com newsletter or
just go to the stronger by science
homepage and click the free programs
button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our Facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional once again thank you for
listening and we will be back soon with
another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]